Et travailleur
auquel le gouvernement veut s'en prendre avec sa loi
immigration censé combattre l'immigration illégale
et réduire l'immigration légale.
À la base de cette loi,
il y a les amalgames mais les mensonges
révoltants de la droite,
de l'extrême droite et du gouvernement,
la personne de Darmanin.
Pour eux, les immigrés, avec ou sans papier,
seraient des profiteurs,
des délinquants, voir des terroristes en puissance,
des profiteurs,
ceux qui sont employés à la semaine ou à la journée
pour travailler dans les pires conditions qui soient
sur les chantiers, euh.
Des Jeux olympiques.
Des profiteurs,
ceux qui payent des cotisations sociales
et qui ne peuvent pas toucher euh.
Les droits qui leur sont liés parce qu'ils travaillent
sous 1 identité d'emprunt.
Ceux que l'on nous présente comme des dangers
sont des travailleuses et des travailleurs.
Ce sont des ouvriers,
ce sont des manutentionnaires,
ce sont des aides-soignantes,
euh. Ce sont tous ceux qui font tourner l'industrie,
l'agroalimentaire, le bâtiment aussi, les hôpitaux,
enfin ce sont ceux qui portent
l'ensemble de la société
avec tous les autres travailleurs.
Et comme n'importe quel travailleur.
Et bien les travailleurs sans-papiers veulent être
respecter et voir leur travail reconnu, et pour cela,
ils se battent
malgré leur précarité
et les risques que cela implique pour eux.
Plusieurs centaines
de travailleurs sans-papiers sont engagés dans des
grèves importantes.
C'est le cas de ceux qui travaillent pour Chronopost
par exemple, mais aussi pour, euh, euh,
beaucoup d'autres qui travaillent sur les chantiers, euh.
Du bâtiment, euh. En particulier sur les Jeux olympiques,
leur combat doit devenir celui de tous les travailleurs,
parce qu'attaquer les immigrés avec ou sans papier,
c'est attaquer le monde ouvrier.
Si les travailleurs sans-papiers sont méprisés,
forcés de raser les murs et surexploités,
et bien cela aura des conséquences
sur l'ensemble du monde du travail,
parce que le patronat en profitera
pour faire pression sur toutes les
conditions de travail
et sur les salaires aussi,
à la baisse.
Nous subissons déjà tous le climat anti-immigré
qui s'est installé,
parce que celui-ci ne frappe pas seulement les immigrés,
légaux ou illégaux de fraîche date,
mais, euh. Ils concernent l'ensemble des immigrés,
parfois installés ici depuis des décennies,
y compris leurs enfants nés en France.
Et puis ils concernent
tous les travailleurs
qui ont, euh. 1 nom ou euh 1 couleur de peau, euh.
Qui laisse supposer qu'il serait d'origine étrangère.
Les travailleurs
qui tombent dans le panneau du racisme
et de la division
se tirent 1 balle dans le pied.
S'il y a des profiteurs dans cette affaire,
ils sont, comme toujours,
dans les rangs du patronat.
Petit, les grands,
ce sont eux qu'il faut dénoncer,
ce sont nos exploiteurs
et ce sont eux qui dirigent la société,
qui l'emmènent dans le mur
en organisant le pillage du monde,
en dressant les peuples les uns contre les autres
et en imposant
leur domination par les guerres.
Ce combat ne peut être mené à bien
que si les travailleurs reconnaissent
dans les travailleurs d'autres origines
D'autres cultures et d'autres couleurs de peau,
des frères de classe et des frères de lutte.